what's going on guys this is Rob and a
lot of you guys have requested that I
make a video on astral regulator Thanos
specifically like the um like a beyond
omega level video and honestly I didn't
know who that like I didn't know what
version of Thanos that was because if
I'm being honest with you guys I have
not really followed Jim starlin's
Infinity Saga after the events of like
Infinity Crusade right like I finished
that and I was kind of like okay cool
I'm kind of done and that was that was
basically it I know he's written a lot
right like Infinity siblings and
infinity Revelations and infinity
relativity and all that I know he's done
all that and we'll go back and cover
those things because some of those
stories are cool others are not but I
think it'd be kind of cool to just sort
of have the whole Infinity Series on my
channel so we'll probably cover like
relativity or Revelations or something
like that after this but you know I I
sat down and I was like okay what in the
heck is astral regulator Thanos and I
looked it up and I was like okay so like
I have to cover this story because this
story is kind of nuts right now here's
the funny thing about it is I understand
it this is what the Thanos win story was
originally intended to be by Jim Starlin
right he was the one you wanted to write
it that when Donnie Cates wrote that
story Jim Stalin wanted to be the one to
create it because Jim Stalin was the one
that did so much with the character of
Thanos so the result of this is that as
we know Thanos wins was a story that was
written you know by Donnie Cates and So
eventually Marvel ended up releasing
this and if I'm being honest with you
guys there's good things about this
story and things that I wasn't really
huge on but it was the same thing with
Thanos wins right there were things that
I loved about it things I didn't really
that I wasn't too big on it I think if
both of these stories were combined it
would be amazing it would be absolutely
ridiculously good because of all the
things that go down here right but the
way that this kicks off is we initially
pick up with Thanos meeting with Adam
Warlock now this comes hot off the heels
of Infinity Gauntlet is really where
this little segment of this story comes
from in the sense that those are the
guys who followed my series on Infinity
gold and infinity war and if you didn't
you'll find both those down in the
description Infinity Gauntlet of course
as most of you guys know is a story
where Thanos discovered and then started
using The Infinity Gauntlet and seized
control of the universe and then
ultimately lost it to nebula an Infinity
war or really the the aftermath kind of
a segue between the too so it was more
of a I guess like a Prelude it was part
of warlock in the infinity watch going
into Infinity War itself The Living
Tribunal basically decreed that Adam
Warlock had to disperse the stones right
the stones would no longer work in
unison The Gauntlet itself wouldn't work
anymore and warlock had to basically
find people who were capable of wielding
the stones but not using them in order
to keep them protected but in order to
make sure that nobody could reassemble
them together again it would seemed like
a moot point because even if they were a
symbol nobody could use them but people
could still use the the individual
Stones hence the reason for the infinity
watch and so during that time we ended
up learning in Infinity war that Thanos
was in possession of the reality Stone
and we didn't initially know that right
we didn't know who who warlock gave the
reality Stone to but in this this little
segment here it's designed to kind of
fill in that little bit of a gap right
because during Infinity War it was like
and then Thanos got the got the reality
Stone and that was basically it and this
is designed to kind of fill in the gaps
and essentially say that that Thanos was
the one who was most suitable to wielded
right because only Thanos could really
comprehend the power of the reality
Stone and be able to maintain that kind
of discipline right because with this
Stone in your possession even your most
subconscious desires become reality you
could fall asleep and dream of like The
Grudge and then like she manifests
because of the reality Stone and then
kills you right so like any number of
those things could could happen if
Thanos was really the only guy who could
maintain that and so what this does is
it picks up you know kind of right now
in the modern day and what it does is it
kind of gives us this idea that Adam
Warlock feels as though something's off
in the universe right something just not
quite right there's some kind of
imminent danger coming now this is part
and parcel to the powers of Adam Warlock
in the sense that he really is very much
a sort of you know jesus-esque character
in Marvel right he dies and he's reborn
over and over and over again he can
never truly be killed he'll always end
up coming back in some form or fashion
at the same time he also kind of has
this Cosmic awareness and through his
experience with the Soul Stone is also
sort of part and parcel to the universe
now how deep reaching this goes and
exactly what this means on like a
definitive concrete level Jim Sterling
has never really explained right it's
almost like the the white Phoenix of the
crown and like her role in the
Multiverse why she just fixes things
that are broken whatever in the hell how
that means and so with Adam Warlock a
lot of it's kind of the same way it's
pretty ambiguous and it really just sort
of allows Marvel and Jim Sterling to
kind of have a blank slate in terms of
what they want to do with this character
and and so on and so forth But
ultimately he ends up basically
traveling alongside pip the troll to go
see Thanos right this is a really cool
moment here because with Pip Patrol of
course he's a long-standing member of
the infinity watch a long-standing
friend of Warlock the two of them have
been together for quite some time but
traveling and seeing Thanos is really
one of the first acts of warlock for a
couple reasons right the first thing is
something seems off and Thanos might
know something but the other part of
this is that the two of them have a very
lengthy relationship they've been on
again off-again allies more so than that
there's a huge amount of respect between
the two and so as Adam Warlock begins
talking to Thanos and saying like you
know there's some kind of dramatic
change that's coming there's a kind of
approaching Darkness it's a cool moment
because Thanos kind of chimes in and
basically says yes you know there is a
kind of Darkness approaching and he
kills Adam Warlock
he's like I am that darkness and right
off the bat Thanos destroys Adam Warlock
like literally incinerates his entire
body pip the troll teleports the hell
out he's like man this is wild peace and
like Bales and then Thanos is just like
take the body and dispose of it done and
so like from there you pick up on the
planet's channel are two weeks later
chandelar of course being the home of
the Shia Empire with Adam Warlock
basically re-emerging after this
two-week period Then the question is
what in the heck is going on right like
why did Thanos kill me now Adam Warlock
doesn't immediately suspect that Thanos
is of some kind of like Terrible
Horrible nefarious plot he believes he's
doing some pretty shady stuff but he
really wants to get more to the bottom
of things and to figure out what's
happening the problem with this is that
once pip Patrol locates Thanos and then
teleports him and Adam Warlock to it
Adam Warlock gets blown up by a missile
he immediately gets destroyed by a
missile and the response of Thanos is
like like when he's talking to his black
order it's like you know yes you know
Adam Warlock will come back but all we
have to do is kill him three times after
that it won't matter and so what he ends
up doing is basically traveling to this
particular location the this particular
artifact looking for a kind of puzzle of
sorts and the reason why really kind of
ties into Infinity siblings and the
sense of what you had in that story is
you had a future version of Thanos that
basically ended up meeting with his
younger self and what does this future
version of Thanos is doing is basically
guiding younger Thanos to some kind of
end goal but he never actually told him
what the end goal was it was just you
have to do these things in order to get
to this point where I'm at and so Thanos
is in a lot of ways blindly following
the orders of his future self under the
idea that one he knows himself so he
trusts himself and two there's going to
be some kind of grand payoff or
something along the way so the result of
this is that once Thanos basically
accesses this particular artifact and
learns of this kind of of map of sorts
you know this particular location that
it's sending him to of course he gets
back aboard his ship and then ultimately
we end up picking up with Star Fox Now
Star Fox or Eros is the brother of
Thanos a lot of you guys probably know
that by now the two of them have a very
very lengthy history Infinity siblings
really push that history in that
relationship to the extreme but it's one
of these things where it's kind of like
okay Eros has a couple and a couple
Tools in his disposal the first one is
that he basically utilized the time
traveling technology of King the
Conqueror and the reason why it was
during the events of infinity siblings
King came to the realization that
somewhere along the line Thanos dies and
when that happens he ultimately ends up
dragging the entirety of the Multiverse
down with the death of Thanos triggers a
cascading effect that brings everything
to an end prematurely so the idea was
that Thanos has to live and so uh came
to conqueror basically orchestrated all
these different events to to ensure that
right so kind of a spoiler for a video
that we're going to cover later on but
the long and short of this is that Eros
had stolen some of the technology of
Kang in order to ensure that should
something happen where Thanos engaged in
some kind of Nefarious pot that Eros can
go back in time and correct it the other
part of this is that a device has
basically been created this exceedingly
small this also based on the technology
of Kang that can be used to essentially
track Thanos right because Eros does not
have that inherent ability the next
thing that really happens here is a new
form of manifestation from Adam Warlock
usually Adam warlock's body always kind
of enters the Cocoon State and Adam
Warlock comes back what ends up
happening here is that some guy ends up
falling off a cliff and that person is
then suddenly encased in a cocoon and
then after a two-week period Adam
Warlock reemerges right so basically
this random being was re-materialized
into Adam Warlock and then Adam Warlock
returned this is not normal it doesn't
usually happen and there is in fact a
force behind everything pulling the
strings when it comes to Adam Warlock
there's a reason why all this is
happening with him and so what it does
from here is it basically picks up with
with Eros you know ultimately tracking
down Thanos and it's kind of this cool
little little moment here because Thanos
of course is looking for Eros under the
guise that his future self informed him
that Eros would become very important
with regards to the various goals they
want to achieve and so while Thanos
cannot kill Eros what he has to do is
essentially find him and then keep him
contained so that he can be used at a
future point in time what that use is
going to be and the role that Eros is
going to play of course we'll find out
at some point you know we'll end up
finding out in this story but you know
from there of course Eros communicating
with Isaac Isaac of course being the
computer of of Titan the one that
basically kind of governs the whole
society and so on ends up using this
tracking device puts it on Thanos and
then makes himself intangible now the
way it is that Eros does this is by
manipulating time and it's a little bit
of a weird thing when it comes to the
notion of phasing in and out of reality
technically speaking the way this works
is that Marvel kind of seems to adopt
this mentality of like things travel in
like one second chunks right so like if
you were one second ahead of me I
wouldn't be able to see you but if
you're a fraction of a second ahead of
me then it means that like you're kind
of this intangible being that I cannot
truly see but you kind of exist in that
same moment I mean because that that
fraction of time is so astronomically
small right so I don't know if that
really makes any sense you know but it's
it's one of those one of those weird
things right like imagine the time it
takes you to turn your head around and
that's really what this is equivalent to
right like it takes you you know if you
were to snap your head back you know it
would take you maybe like one and a half
seconds to do but like in that one and a
half second period you've also got
exceedingly shorter amounts of time
fractions of a second and what Marvel's
doing here really what Jim Sterling's
doing here is introducing this idea that
eros's ability to manipulate time is
such that it's not putting him seconds
ahead of Thanos is putting him fractions
of a second ahead of Thanos which means
he's essentially in the same moment that
Thanos is in but because he's kind of
out of phase meaning he's fractions of a
second ahead Thanos cannot really see
him right it's one of these weird things
right like how can you interact with
something that doesn't know you're there
when you're technically not there it's
weird and it's really finicky I
understand if you're totally baffled and
totally confused it's just one of those
plot points that Marvel creates in order
to achieve a certain goal and so what
ends up happening here is of course Adam
Warlock and pip end up tracking down
Thanos and once they arrive Thanos has
already left for the area but then of
course they end up arriving and meeting
with Eros and this is a very welcome
Ally given the history between these
characters the fact that Eros has
consistently worked to thwart the
schemes of Thanos right so they're
allies in that regard and bringing to
bear this information that Eros has put
a tracking device on Thanos in order to
locate him and he also has the ability
to manipulate time is a cool little
thing because it means it's basically
they're out if they choose or have the
opportunity to use it the other part of
this is that as they're talking Adam
Warlock gets hit with a missile again
it just comes out of nowhere Just Hits
him and then Adam Warlock is of course
destroyed right that's the end of that
now pip Patrol ends up teleporting away
but basically it's one of these things
where pip and and uh and heroes have
this conversation of hey like we have
our chance to basically combine our
information and to figure out what this
bigger picture is right it's kind of
like the Illuminati effect that used in
their information that they become
greater than the sum of their parts and
so from there you end up seeing Thanos
more or less being teleported away and
encountering his future self now this
future version of Thanos is amazing
looking right like he looks like
eternity with the face of mistress death
like I don't know it's kind of wild like
having him look this way it looks kind
of crazy but he looks like a cosmic
entity so the question is how did Thanos
achieve this level of power and the way
in which he gets to that point is
actually pretty solid because what this
does is it basically leads to Thanos and
his future self having this conversation
now his future self is again pretty
ambiguous here again it's that
conversation Eros is going to be
important you can't kill him you have to
capture him you have to hold on to him
so on and so forth but you also have a
tracking device on you right so like
make sure you get rid of that so Eros
cannot find you that kind of a thing
ultimately because Eros is aligned with
Pip and because pip has the ability to
track Thanos no matter where he is
doesn't really matter at all but what we
end up having here is is basically
future Thanos and what passes for
present-day Thanos concluding their
conversation and then you end up having
Eros and hit the troll of course
teleport to thanos's location and when
they get there this planet the the
planet zeltia I think is what it is the
last time Eros was here during the
events of infinity siblings the place
was a very Lush and welcome environment
right it was beautiful it was like a
giant rainforest very tropical and
gorgeous something seems to have
happened here that laid waste to the
entire location and so when the question
is like have you teleported us to the
wrong place the response is no like this
entire place has basically been totally
annihilated or totally destroyed and
what you have here is that this location
has been transformed into the realm of
mistress death that's what this is now
right it's the realm of death which is
really kind of weird because mistress
death does not occupy a physical plane
she doesn't really exist on any one
particular physical planet right you
can't get on a spaceship and fly to the
realm of mistress death she exists as an
other dimensional entity she literally
exists in the afterlife right so I mean
I guess you could you could get on a
ship and fly to the afterlife if the
ship explodes or like flies into a star
and you die then sure you can get to the
afterlife but you can't physically go
there I mean I guess you can if you can
manipulate dimensional barriers like
Doctor Strange or somebody like that or
like Thanos but what it does is it
switches back over to Thanos and him
basically just sort of sitting in space
and where corvus glaive and the
outriders don't really know why he's
there they don't really know what's
going on like like what they're waiting
for thanos's response is I've been
informed that at this point there's
going to be an object or a device
passing through here and my job is to
take it and so it's kind of like okay
like we'll see how this goes which is
kind of wild and ultimately it ends up
being a comet that flies through there
now Thanos of course ends up traveling
to the comet by himself and this is an
interesting thing because it's not just
any regular comment the more important
thing to come out of this is that Thanos
States whatever this object is and he
basically says it's power of a magnitude
exceeding that of the infinity gems
right so whatever this object is it's
Way Beyond the power of the Infinity
Stones which really of course interests
Thanos because you always been on a
quest to attain absolute power the
problem with this is that the device
hidden inside of the object hidden
inside this this comet is not something
that can just be arbitrarily attained
right I mean you know it's not like you
know it was created and then just
dropped off on Earth somewhere and like
it's just been sitting in a convenience
store it can't be one of those things
where just anybody can get their hands
on it that there's all kinds of Power
protecting it you know like this kind of
cosmic energy source and so Thanos of
course starts ripping it apart starts
pulling it away and in the process he
himself begins undergoing disintegration
his body starts breaking down the power
is really more than his physical form
can handle which really speaks volumes
to how much power we're talking about
here because the kind of energy that's
needed to physically damage Thanos is
astronomical really what happens here is
once he breaks through to the core of
this Comet and he secures this object
for himself then what it appears to be
is this kind of orb of sorts now we'll
find out exactly what this is and what
is what it's able to do but from there
Thanos when he kind of Muses and asks
the question you're like I'm not really
even sure what this is for myself of
course this future version just kind of
seems to appear to Thanos and it says
it's both promise and a mystery take
this thing and use it and I promise all
your questions will be answered and so
what it does is it leads to Thanos
showing up to the realm of mistress
death and of course as soon as he
arrives here Thanos is told you cannot
be here and that's the way it usually is
right Thanos has been banned from the
realm of mistress death for quite some
time right he's not really welcome here
and the thing about him showing up is
he's really kind of musing and saying
like for all the people who tell me that
I cannot come here which of you is going
to stop me right how many times have I
come in here and mistress death says I
can't be here and then she sends some
Force after me and then I totally
destroy it who's gonna stop me are you
guys gonna stop me and Thanos of course
annihilates all the henchmen and the
various people that are there to prevent
him from staying in the realm of
mistress death they're all completely
destroyed and then Thanos begins
speaking directly to death herself and
says how many times have you spurned my
advances how many times have I made my
affections known to you and you've
rejected me how many times has that
happened well nevertheless if I cannot
possess then I shall become and using
this object Thanos transfers the energy
into mistress death pulls her into
himself eradicates Mr death entirely and
Thanos himself becomes the new death in
the last video we basically kind of had
this idea where you essentially had like
future Thanos right and Thanos in this
future looked like eternity but whatever
it was that happened to him he seemingly
became this like omnipotent sort of
character the idea behind this is that
that modern day Thanos is more or less
being Guided by Future Thanos so we'll
kind of get a an answer to that question
a sort of of explanation as to what's
going on but with Eros the brother of
Thanos and pip the troll trying to
figure out what Thanos is doing and then
in turn trying to find a way to defeat
him they've essentially just been
following him throughout what he's been
doing right so the idea was that Thanos
had essentially managed to find some way
to acquire a particular artifact a
particular device called the the astral
regulator or the cosmic regulator and
then destroyed mistress death and really
like absorbed her Essence into himself
and then became the new death basically
mean the Thanos Now controls the realm
of the afterlife and so where he
essentially teleports away Eros and pip
the troll follow him but they don't know
exactly where he's going the best they
can do is just kind of jump forward
through time using their advice taken by
King the Conqueror and then just try to
understand what it is that's happening
right so this is really just guess and
check and so what they do is jump a year
into the future and when they arrive
here in the future galactus's ship had
basically just kind of Crash landed into
this realm and when they start
inspecting they start looking around
they basically come to the realization
that Thanos has been exceedingly busy
that not only did Thanos destroy and
absorb Galactus Thanos has also absorbed
the Infinity Stones he's absorbed Master
order Lord Chaos The Stranger sire hate
mistress love he basically absorbed all
the cosmic entities into himself and
he's been busy now all this happened off
panel I'm not really skipping over
anything we literally go from one page
to this page he's basically just been
absorbing all the cosmic entities into
himself but the reality of where Eros
and pip the troll are is that it's just
kind of like all right so there's not a
whole lot we can do here right like in
the present moment right now there's
nothing we can do to defeat Thanos like
we're gonna have to find a way to go
back in time and to basically keep this
from happening now here's here's the
cool thing before you bounce Jim Stalin
plays time exceedingly Smart in this
story he does it in a really really cool
way and that's one of the things that a
lot of writers kind of run into one of
the problems they run into then just ran
into that problem when it came to
Matthew Malloy different writers run
into time travel with different problems
and more often than not it's usually
invoked as a means to end a story Jim
Starlin passes that and basically copes
with it in spectacular fashion but the
cool thing about this is that Adam
Warlock you know where you end up having
pip Patrol and uh and and Eros who
basically kind of jump forward and
continue their journey and figuring out
what the end game of Thanos is Adam
Warlock is resurrected and one of the
things that we had talked about in the
last video is that Adam Warlock coming
back the way that he did was kind of
abnormal it didn't always happen that
way that he always kind of had a
particular Form and Function right like
a cocoon would manifest somewhere and
Adam Warlock would start to regenerate
inside of it and then ultimately he
would come out he'd make his presence
known and whatever story was going on
that required him to be in that event
what was going on here were things like
it was a resurrection process that
wasn't normal right and so what this
meant was that Adam Warlock didn't know
entirely what was going on and so when
he basically hops back up and really
kind of asks the question what's going
on with these changes in my resurrection
process he's met by the arrival of the
Living Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
basically says I'm the one behind all
this like I'm the reason why you're
resurrecting the way that you are now
one of the funny things about this is
that when when Adam Warlock starts
asking questions like okay well what's
going on like like you know why am I
here that kind of a thing but Living
Tribunal says like we're outside of
reality but like you are outside of the
norm now there's a very particular
meaning to that and we will find out
what that meaning is later on in this
video but the two of them get in a very
in-depth discussion and the reason why
is because of course you have the Living
Tribunal kind of like is this
multiversal overseer right so even if
the Living Tribunal can be destroyed his
job is to watch the Multiverse and to
safeguard it as best you can and so
there's nothing that takes place inside
of a universe across the entirety of the
Multiverse that the Living Tribunal
doesn't know about whether or not he can
stop it is a whole different argument
but he's always aware of everything
that's happening right so multiversal
awareness it's part and parcel to his
role but of course Adam Warlock also
addresses the idea of the Living
Tribunal this version is basically an
alternate reality version of Adam
Warlock those of you guys who recall
that in the aftermath of Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers and
Secret Wars when the Living Tribunal and
all the cosmic entities were destroyed
Jim Starlin wrote an Infinity comic that
was a tie-in to it all more or less so
it's kind of a loose event but the
notion was uh the one above all needed a
new Living Tribunal since the beyonders
destroyed the previous one and so Adam
Warlock from an alternate reality was
made into the New Living Tribunal so
that's just kind of a quick 30 second or
a minute explanation but as to the
astral regulator it has as to how it is
Thanos has this level of power this all
basically comes through an explanation
from The Living Tribunal and this is a
really really cool concept introduced by
uh by Jim Starlin this actually built on
something else right so for the longest
time when it came to the Multiverse in
Marvel Jim Starland had introduced
different things like the custodian of
the Multiverse and so on and so forth
but the idea here is that we of course
have an infinite number of universes out
there the question that we always sort
of asked here is what keeps one Universe
from crossing over into another what Jim
Starling gives us here is the astral
regulator and what he says is that in
every single universe that exists out
there there is an astro regulator right
every Universe exists for every
possibility but the Living Tribunal
chimes in and says the astral Regulators
are basically there to ensure that no
Universe crosses over into another this
is in fact Jim starlin's adaptation of
DC's Source wall that's more or less
what this is right the idea that the
source wall that every Universe has its
own source wall then the Multiverse has
its own source wall and these are
literal barriers around universes and
around the Multiverse that are designed
to prevent universes from crossing over
into other universes and multiverses
from crossing over into other
multiverses Jim Starlin essentially
taking that idea and rolling it over and
basically saying the astral regulator is
designed for the purpose of ensuring
that no Universe crosses over into
another but it's a very complex Network
right and so essentially Thanos taking
it has kind of destabilized things and
again we'll talk more about that here in
a little bit but what the Living
Tribunal tells Adam Warlock is Thanos is
working towards the notion of not
Conquering the universe as we saw him do
an Infinity Gauntlet it's not like that
where he's getting the Infinity Stones
slapping him on a glove and then
basically replacing eternity Thanos is
going for something much much grander
Thanos is trying to become the entirety
of reality and that's why future Thanos
looks the way he does he looks like
eternity because that future version of
Thanos seemingly has achieved that level
of power he is all that is he's all in
existence and so the result of this is
is you basically have the tribunal
tasking Adam Warlock with the idea of
being the person that's going to
essentially find a way to defeat Thanos
now in truth a lot of people could
probably undertake this role but Jim
Starlin chose Adam Warlock because the
entirety of the infinity line of stories
going from Infinity Gauntlet all the way
up to this story and in really Infinity
ending ties into the idea that there's
just something unique and special about
Thanos and Adam Warlock now again Adam
Warlock outside the norm will kind of
cover that here in a little bit but they
are indeed wholly unique characters they
are indeed characters where for the most
part yes they exist in different
realities but they stand away from
everybody else right they stand separate
from everybody else insofar as how they
compare to like all the doctor strange
is and all the cyclopses and all the
Captain America's and all the
Spider-Mans and all the Wolverines and
Phoenix forces and so on and so forth
and so what this does is it basically
leads to this idea that Adam Warlock has
to do something in order to defeat
Thanos and so he's kind of tasked by the
tribunal since he's really the only one
that can seemingly pull this off now
picking back up with Eros and pip Patrol
they kind of do this jumping around the
universe right they end up jumping into
the future a little bit further and they
hop skip and around the universe they go
by Earth they go by all these different
places the space station or the
celestial head of nowhere The Planet Of
mord The Planet Of spartax The Brood
World a scroll Outpost rigel all these
different places they've all been
destroyed by Thanos right like all life
has been totally eradicated by Thanos
like even down to the microscopic level
nothing exists there anymore and so what
this does is it picks up with a loving
tribunal meeting with the one above all
now we never get to see this in Marvel
Comics we never really see what happens
when the Living Tribunal meets with the
one above all that usually never ever
ever happens and in fact as far as I'm
aware this is the first time in Marvel
Comics we've actually gotten to see the
two of them Converse in this capacity
usually it's the Living Tribunal saying
something like I represent a power of
this Beyond on everything or whatever it
is you know he's just super op beyond
beyond omega level is what he is but the
one above all basically tells the Living
Tribunal what's going on in this one
Universe threatens all of creation right
it threatens all things in existence
what's happened here is threatening
everything now one of the cool things
that goes on is the one above all's face
shifts he changes from 1-1 race to
another to another to another and so
it's kind of a cool theme to kind of see
this melding and switching and changing
that the one above all is not a finite
construct right like he's just kind of
this representation of everything that
exists out there and what the one above
all says is this astral regulator is
designed to regulate the entirety of the
Multiverse that is not as small beans as
the Living Tribunal thought it was right
the Living Tribunal looked at this and
said okay so basically Thanos taking the
astral regulator creates a cosmic
imbalance and my job is to enforce that
and because he's kind of outside the
norm and he has a level of power and so
on and so forth Adam Warlock you go take
care of it what the what above all says
is no you fail to grasp the complexity
of this now this is super important
because it hits this idea that despite
all of his wanted power The Living
Tribunal is not an immutable all-knowing
Force right like he's basically he's
screwed up here is really what it is
right he misjudged he misunderstood the
complexity and how extreme the situation
is what the one above all says is the
astral regulator of each Universe yes
they exist their purpose is to keep a
universe from crossing over with another
but the truth of this is that they're
all tied into a network so what's
basically gone on here is Thanos is
playing a giant game of Jenga and he's
starting to pull out the wrong pieces
and it's only a matter of time before
this whole thing comes Crashing Down by
taking this astral regulator and pulling
it away from his role and then
repurposing it for the for the reason of
giving himself omnipotence he's upset
the multiversal balance right the
balance of all existence not only that
what he's doing can actually happen he
could become the entirety of reality
itself in essence the one above all now
views Thanos as a credible threat and
that's what's so crazy about this right
Thanos is at a level of power now for
the one above all is legitimately
concerned and at the end of the day it
all comes down down to Adam Warlock to
be the one to pull it off and so that's
why all these things are really sort of
crazy here that's why it's so chaotic
it's because what we do is we basically
jump to you know present-day Thanos for
lack of a better word who's absorbed all
these Cosmic entities meeting with his
future self right the one that is
essentially merged with all of reality
and the whole reason behind this is the
fact that future Thanos is is fearful of
the fact that somebody will figure out
what he's doing and basically stop his
younger self and that's the cool thing
here right this is Jim saw him playing
it smart with reality that we would look
at this and we would say okay so if
present-day Thanos is talking to his
future self and his future self becomes
uh connected to all all of reality he
becomes everything in existence
presumably you know transcending the one
above all in the Living Tribunal and all
that then like why would he concern
himself with like making sure his
younger self gets there and the reason
why is because anybody could screw it up
at any point in time it's one thing to
achieve that role but the reality of
what Thanos has learned with regards to
the Multiverse is the fact that there's
an infinite number of realities out
there and anything can happen somebody
can pop up they can be at the right
place of the right time and so
essentially guiding himself right making
sure that like the things that could get
in his way don't get in his way right
that just because he ended up in this
future you know and became this being
doesn't mean that it's guaranteed right
like if for example he was supposed to
kill Adam Warlock at a particular point
in time and he didn't everything gets
thrown off and any number of things can
cause that to happen right any number of
things can can get in there and so what
you do is you pick up basically with
Eros and with uh with Pip Patrol kind of
coming to this conclusion it's sort of a
red herring here the way gemstone plays
it because it's like okay so like
they're gonna go back in time they're
going to kill Thanos when he's a baby
and basically stop the future okay so
like this is like and and there are some
writers out there who would say and this
is how we end the story guys thanks for
watching you know Jim Starlin does this
and before Eros can pull it off Adam
Warlock pops up and says if you do that
nothing will happen this not going to
work because what's going to happen here
is things are going to be worse and this
is really Jim Sterling tying into
everything he's done with regards to
Adam Warlock and Thanos in the entire
Infinity Series right the relationship
between the two and when Jim Stalin was
riding the old Adam Warlock comics the
relationship between Adam Warlock and
Thanos was that Thanos had actually come
to the aid of Adam Warlock and helping
Adam defeat his own future evil
counterpart the Magus you know magus's
attempts to basically gain the The
Infinity Gauntlet for himself during the
events of infinity War Thanos being part
of warlock in the infinity watch and
basically having the reality Stone and
then giving a false Stone to uh the
Magus is what led to nagus's defeat at
the end of the whole thing right he had
an Affinity Gauntlet but he wasn't all
powerful because he didn't have all the
Infinity Stones what Adam says here is
that if Eros kills Thanos as a baby then
it means at each one of those pivotal
moments throughout the entirety of the
universe when Thanos helps him defeat
the Magus when Thanos gives the Magus a
false reality Stone when each one of
those things takes place that it won't
happen and the future that's going to
come out of that is going to be a future
where the Magus will dominate all of
reality and put the kind of things that
Thanos did during Infinity Gauntlet and
infinity war and infinity Crusade and
the infinity siblings and all that kind
of stuff it'll put all that to shame and
so of course Eros basically backs off
his actions and destroying Thanos as a
baby and and they essentially teleport
back to the modern day or 2018 at the
time this is being done to the base of
where Eros is operating at and when the
question is what do we do here you know
if this plan of killing Thanos is a baby
is not going to work then what plan do
you have and Adam Warlock says this and
he kills he kills Eros if the troll
begins to freak out but the response of
Adam Warlock is according to the Living
Tribunal this is the only thing that's
going to work and so what we do is we
basically jump back to the future with
with Thanos uh who's essentially
absorbed all these various Cosmic
entities and this this you know we'll
call them like primitive Thanos more or
less in comparison to his like Ultra
powerful future counterpart but
primitive Thanos is met by the arrival
of Eternity and he was told by his
future version
eternity and infinity are really a
couple of the last stops that you have
before this entire thing is is taken
care of right before it's all done and
so what this does is it leads to a
conflict between the two now the cool
thing about this and I love how Jim
Sterling plays on this Thanos this is
not his first time up to back he's done
this dance he's played this game he
understands the the significance of
Eternity and infinity the power that
they wield but Thanos is not concerned
about either of them because the power
he possesses in the form of the astral
regulator is Way Beyond The Power of of
infinity and Eternity and so where they
show up here and they basically start
using their various abilities to try to
destroy Thanos we jump back to Eros and
Eros of course having been killed in the
modern day ends up traveling to the
realm of mistress death because at the
time that he died Thanos had not killed
an absorbed mistress death yet and so
what it meant is that basically being
there mistress death is aware of the
plot that Thanos has and his attempts to
like basically show up on her doorstep
and kill her at some future point in
time which kind of makes sense being a
cosmic entity that understands the
Notions of like life and death and
things like that it makes sense that she
would be aware of that and so with that
being the case she believes Eros is
there as a spy and so in order to
resolve the situation she banishes Eros
from her realm that action right there
is what saves all things in existence
like that action right there is why Eros
is so important and that's why Adam
Warlock killed him is because that one
thing is going to essentially be this
Saving Grace or at least I assume it is
right and so transitioning back to
Thanos facing off against eternity and
infinity the reality is they're really
more Pomp and Circumstance here than
anything anything else they're blowing a
bunch of hot air that for all their talk
of like you're going to fall we're going
to destroy you all that kind of stuff
it's really just more Pride than
anything else in the face of the astral
regulator and the power that it
represents and the face of of all these
vaunted abilities that he has infinity
and Eternity fall and it's kind of crazy
because the conflict between the two of
them basically spans like all things in
existence right it expands all of time
and space across the universe itself all
time Across the Universe like everything
across the entirety of the universe is
felt by them from the universe's very
Beginnings all the way to its very end
the point at which it dies like this is
what we're talking about here this is
the kind of level of power that we're
discussing because that's what these
characters represent infinity represents
Time and Eternity represents space and
so to fight them is to fight all of time
and space and so that's why these these
conflicts between these beings literally
have shock waves across the entirety of
the universe's history and the space the
universe occupies it's like being able
to witness an explosion all at the same
time right so like there's like comic
bomb that goes off or some kind of
explosion doesn't matter what it is but
like you see it and then a person from
500 years ago sees the exact same
explosion and a person in a thousand
years sees the exact same explosion some
kind of an event across all time and
space I know it's super meta and I know
it seems kind of kind of crazy and a
little mind-bending but that's what
we're talking about when we're talking
about Cosmic entities but regardless of
how hard they fight and regardless of
what tricks they pull up their sleeve
and the sense of infinity manipulating
time and trying to like age Thanos and
or you know try to destroy Thanos and
the collapse of his physical form and
all that kind of stuff none of it works
and the two of them are absorbed into
themselves and when that happens Thanos
is confronted with the with the Living
Tribunal and the Living Tribunal
basically appears here and says this
cannot be allowed to stand this amount
of power that you have what you've done
it's created an incredible imbalance in
the universe itself more so than that
you threaten the entirety of the
Multiverse there's nothing to negotiate
here there's nothing for us to talk
about youth Thanos are going to have to
fall and so what we do is we jump back
to Eros and so Eros resurrecting
basically coming back from the dead
having been banished from Mystery death
this is what the Living Tribunal was
referring to by being outside the norm
that Adam Warlock can never die Adam
Warlock will live forever he will always
resurrect no matter how you kill him no
matter what means it is that he's his
physical body is destroyed somebody
somewhere will be walking and like
they'll die they'll just kill over from
a heart attack or they'll be hit by a
bus and they'll be used as the method by
which Adam Warlock returns Thanos has
been banished from the realm of mistress
death he was banished from her realm
long before the story took place right
he was banned he can never ever die like
now Eros is the exact same way they
exist outside the norm because they're
immutable forces now right they're not
really on par with Cosmic entities and
so far as like they're all powerful it's
not really that way it's simply the
natural order of things which is things
are born and things die and then there's
them they're outside the norm they're
outside the natural order and so that's
the reason why why Eros is so important
here is because with him and Adam
Warlock working together presumably they
should be able to defeat Thanos and so
following this we pick up basically with
this massive destruction you know this
massive explosion seemingly in the
entirety of this system and the defeat
of the Living Tribunal and that's why
this is important is because when you
think of a fight between the Living
Tribunal and you think of the Living
Tribunal as destruction most likely you
think of Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers because that's really the only
time that we ever saw that happening
like the only time we saw before that
was during Marvel the end and it was
really more of Thanos absorbing all of
reality into himself and then recreating
it again usually when you think of like
an extremely powerful being like the
Living Tribunal being destroyed you
think of like this massive explosion of
energy that would just shatter the
entirety of the Multiverse it's like
it's like it's like grabbing a brick and
just throwing it into a into a glass
house right it's just it's gonna shatter
the entire thing right it's gonna it's
gonna destroy some part of the Glass
House and the rest of it's gonna
collapse under its own way right that's
kind of how you you assume that
situation to be the way this plays out
though is again it's basically just this
idea of Thanos absorbing The Living
Tribunal into himself but that's where
Thanos is now at this moment right now
Thanos has absorbed The Living Tribunal
into himself or at least that seems to
be the case now things are going to be
explained a little bit more at a future
point in time but like Thanos basically
jumps in with his future counterpart
like starts talking to him and and
essentially his future counterpart says
you are now where I am right like we are
now where we're supposed to be you have
achieved the level of power I've wanted
you to achieve we are now one and
literally they merge into a singular
being right now this is just Jim
starlin's Way of rectifying the time
stream the future version of Thanos got
modern day Thanos to this level of power
and the two of them are now occupying
the same space at the same time the
truth is that they're a singular being
right they're the same person both
cannot exist at the same time and so
they basically become the singular
person and when that happens Thanos says
now the real game begins now I Thanos
who am essentially the sum total of all
of reality will go forward and I will
face off against the one above all okay
so we are getting into Infinity ending
and here's the funny thing I initially
plan on waiting until like next week to
start this but you guys have been
screaming at me when we covered Infinity
conflict to start this next part
so I was like okay I mean I don't really
see a reason not to but there's a couple
things I do want to explain here because
there was a little bit of uh uncertainty
that I noticed in the comments section
some of you guys seemed a little unsure
and so the way this has played out so
far is we essentially had like two
versions of Thanos right we had
present-day Thanos and then we had
future Thanos and the future Thanos had
somehow found a way to essentially
absorb all these various Cosmic entities
right everybody from localized and
smaller Cosmic entities like mistress
death or eternity or Infinity all the
way up to like the Living Tribunal and
so initially the question was why is he
working with his younger self and the
idea was that he was guiding present-day
Thanos through a series of steps to
ensure his own Survival right to ensure
that he would become the person he
became you know with regards to Future
Thanos and so the result of this is that
from there the question was okay then if
there's something standing in his path
then why doesn't he stop that and this
really came into play with the death of
Eros and the nature of Adam Warlock in
the sense that as we talked about in the
last video Adam Warlock is essentially
Immortal he'll always come back right no
matter how he dies and no matter how
much time passes he'll always return
this basically placed Adam Warlock
outside of the norm because he does not
abide by the normal rules of life and
death when Eros was killed by Adam
Warlock Adam Warlock had hoped that
mistress death would banish Eros from
her realm for whatever reason either
because she understood Adam warlock's
goal in killing him or because she
believed that Eros was going to be
working alongside Thanos to basically
usurp her role whatever the reason was
we knew that it was because she was
afraid that Eros was working alongside
Thanos she banished Eros from her realm
and that in turn landed Eros outside the
norm because he now no longer abides by
the normal rules of life and death he's
essentially Immortal he can never really
die and so having said this what it did
is it led up to this massive battle and
that was actually kind of a little bit
of a portion that seems a little murky
here we essentially had a scenario where
Thanos had absorbed The Living Tribunal
into himself what makes this kind of
crazy is that as this comic picks up
we've got the one above all and then
you've got the Living Tribunal there
right so I don't know this is some kind
of an error or if I misinterpreted it
you know however was does that happen
but literally in the preface of the book
like as you open it up and you know one
of the last things it says is like you
know present-day Thanos has killed the
last embodiment The Living Tribunal
itself and merged with its despotic
future self right so like he absorbed
The Living Tribunal so the question is
how is the Living Tribunal here that's
really kind of how this is now at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
because when this happens the one above
all basically tells Thanos to stop right
to stop his actions and to in turn to go
back to his normal role and Thanos says
no now the question that a lot of people
have here and that I noticed was a lot
of people were asking if the one above
all is this nion omnipotent
indestructible and immutable Force
inside the entirety of the Marvel
Multiverse then why doesn't it just will
Thanos out of existence right there's
nothing though the one of them all
cannot do and the reason why is because
Jim Starlin is basically altering the
form and function of the one above all
and stories from years past right old
Fantastic Four stories old Sensational
Spider-Man Stories the role of the one
above all was essentially kind of a
prime mover in the sense that like he
created the first Universe we saw that
in Al Ewing's ultimates and then the
first Universe basically fractured when
the aspirins and the celestials went to
war and then those fractured pieces
created the first Multiverse and by
whatever Manner and whatever means those
different universes came to an end and
then were reborn again but the one above
all didn't really sit back and then like
create the first Multiverse and then
every time a universe dies he creates a
new one he just sort of set things in
motion and they went through whatever
path they went through but regardless of
his Hands-On or or lack thereof his
hands on approach with the Multiverse
the reality was there's nothing the one
above all cannot do he represents the
writers or the artists or Stan Lee or
Jack Kirby whichever depiction you want
to go with depending on which comic
you're reading at the time Jim staron is
basically modifying that and what he
says here is this idea that the the one
above all is actually not really a slave
to the structure of the Multiverse but
he can't break its rules that the one
above all basically created all things
in existence and there are certain
safeguards there that not even the one
above all can can get past which really
kind of defies his purpose right it's
kind of like that that old school
Quagmire can God create an object that's
too heavy for him to lift that's really
what this is right right you know kind
of this idea of defying omnipotence and
so that's why it seemed a little strange
because the one above all should be able
to just will Thanos out of existence
that it should just kind of end that way
but the result is that when you're
invoking something like this you can't
right you can't on one hand bring in the
one above all and basically kind of
create a scenario where Thanos traces
off against him in any believable way if
like the one above all is this immutable
and indestructible force that nothing
can stop and so what happens is over the
span of the first three pages the one
above all and I guess the Living
Tribunal you know in this instance face
off against Thanos and Thanos
immediately absorbs them and so
essentially Thanos has now become the
new one above all and that's the crazy
thing about this right it happens like
that in the blink of an eye and it's a
wild situation because you literally
have Adam Warlock and who have Eros and
you have Pip the troll watching this
whole thing go down and when Thanos
re-emerges Thanos is now all things in
existence from that point going forward
they bail Eros grabs pip Patrol he grabs
Adam Warlock with the intention of
teleporting away Adam Warlock Yanks his
hand away Eros and pit Patrol are gone
and Adam Warlock ran behind and talking
to Thanos you know the new one above all
we kind of get this explanation right
this sort of explanation in terms of
what he can do and so on and so forth
now what's also interesting is he points
out this notion that because of the fact
that Adam Warlock and Eros exist outside
of the of the norm fifth Thanos while he
can detect them has to work hard to do
it right they're not just easily
perceptible to him it's almost like a
it's almost like trying to detect a dark
gray amidst a black background right
it's possible you just really have to be
looking for it and so because of that
Adam Warlock one immediately picks up on
that and then two you end up having
Thanos who basically pulls Adam Warlock
into himself with the purpose of always
being able to locate Adam Warlock right
to kind of remove that aspect and then
from there Thanos starts to Muse and
this is normal for for Jim Sterling it's
actually one of the things that always
made his handling of Thanos so cool the
way he would write Thanos was really
more of he would see himself almost kind
of like in a philosophical way right he
would he would kind of muse about these
things he says now I am linked to all
there is right he's not actually I mean
he is all there is but he's linked into
everything right everything from the
past and the Press throughout every
single universe that exists and it's
almost overwhelming right it's almost
overwhelming for Thanos to sit down and
say all actualities all realities that
exist out there every universe that
exists in the entirety of the Multiverse
I am all those things this is a whole
new level of power that's Way Beyond
anything Thanos has ever had before the
closest he ever got to this was during
Marvel the end when he absorbed the
Multiverse into himself and then brought
it back with death basically being
permanent meaning nobody could be
resurrected again it was kind of a
criticism of Marvel in the sense they
always killed and brought back people
and to basically kind of remove that or
try to make it in continuity Marvel
ultimately said no because they like
being able to kill people and then bring
them back later it makes for good click
bait storytelling what it does show here
is really kind of the role of the one
above all in terms of all the various
forms that it exists in and when it
comes to the one above all in Marvel
it's one of these things where like it's
it's Marvel's version of The Presence
from DC and the presence is like DC's
version of the one above all right and
what I mean by that is what you have
inside of of the comic book landscape
you have a singular Universe then you
have stuff like an over so you have an
underverse so on and so forth but the
the the broad broad Strokes here that
you have a singular Universe then you
have a Multiverse and then you have
What's called the Omniverse and the way
this works is that a universe is a
universe right it's just a singular
universe that you occupy the main Marvel
Universe the Ultimate Universe the
Marvel Cinematic Universe those those
different universes make up the entirety
of the Multiverse the Omniverse is
composed of all things in existence
right so there's the Marvel Multiverse
and the DC Multiverse and the spawn
Multiverse and like like any concept
that exists out there is part of the
greater Omniverse and Marvel's one above
all is kind of a guy who oversees all
that right as Marvel's God above all
gods essentially so it's it's one of
these things where they all kind of
cross over and all gets really weird and
it's not really designed to say that
like the one above all is over the
presence it's Marvel kind of saying I
mean our version is and then DC is like
no our version is and spawns like no no
you're both wrong our version is so it's
it's kind of one of these things where
it just sort of goes around but Thanos
is basically tapping into and overseeing
everything across every every single
Universe in every single Multiverse on
every single property that exists in the
world belonging to anybody regardless of
whoever made it that's how far reaching
this is and so it gets kind of crazy
here because with that being the case
Eros kind of picks up on the notion of
what we talked about already that Thanos
cannot easily recognize him because he's
outside the norm Thanos has to hunt for
him as hard as he possibly can right a
needle in a stack of needles is really
what this is and so with that being the
case because pip Patrol is essentially
viewed as Thanos as one of the people
out there who can throw a wrench in the
works then what Eros does is basically
tear up a backpack more or less and then
put pit Patrol inside of it so that PIV
Patrol is as close to Eros as he can
possibly be and by extension of Eros
being outside the norm that will
hopefully kind of permeate to pip the
troll now it really kind of seems to be
this idea that it's not really like an
arrow-shaped hole in the universe if
that makes sense almost kind of like a
permeation of like this energy that
makes him outside the norm that
hopefully will also Encompass uh
Encompass pip Patrol that kind of seems
to be what he's shooting for and Jim
Sterling plays it fast and loose we
don't really get any definitive and
answers there but we're kind of more or
less left to believe that is actually
the case and so what ends up happening
is is Eros and pit Patrol basically say
okay fine then let's see what's going on
let's see if we can find a way to defeat
Thanos in the past or whatever it is
kind of throwing out these various
mcguffins here and you end up having
Euros to pick the trolls show up on the
ship of Thanos which is currently
occupied by corvus Glade and Proxima
midnight but then they vanish they
disappear and Eros figures out this is
happening because what Thanos is doing
is getting rid of anybody who knows his
plan and who could potentially find a
way to take him out that's what's so
cool about this is Thanos just kind of
getting rid of people here and there but
this is the one thing to understand here
and this is this is awesome the way Jim
Sterling does it Thanos is handling his
omnipotence and his power the way a
mortal person would Thanos is not
handling his abilities the way the one
above all would and there's a huge
distinction there and we'll find out
what that distinction is as we get
through this video but from there you
pick up with Adam Warlock who basically
emerges after having been ensnared by
Thanos with thanos's ability to see him
and essentially locates Kane the conquer
now again Kane the Conqueror was from a
previous Infinity story but it was by
virtue of Kane the Conqueror that Eros
managed to attain his time traveling
technology as well as a few other things
going on but what this means is that
using the ability of King to manipulate
time Adam Warlock seemingly has some bit
of an out and so from here we jump to
one of the most important parts of the
story when we pick up with present-day
Thanos and present-day Thanos his
Consciousness is basically Inside the
Mind Of Future Thanos right like this
version of Thanos that merged with the
one above all and all that kind of stuff
that's future Thanos who's done all that
present-day Thanos is just kind of a
Consciousness that's along for the ride
and it's cool when he basically talks
about this right he says things like yes
I'm still here like you know I was I was
basically press gained into this
situation but what it shows is that
their ideologies are not entirely linked
present-day Thanos is not fully on board
with what future Thanos is doing what he
knows his plan he knows what he wants to
achieve but even for modern day Thanos
that seems pretty extreme and that says
something like given whatever this
future plan or whatever this plan of
future Thanos is if present-day Thanos
looks at that and says yeah man like
that's pretty crazy man like that's
pretty extreme that means it's really
got to be something right because we're
talking about a guy who got a hold of
The Infinity Gauntlet and wiped out half
the life in the universe just to impress
a girl right so like it's kind of crazy
like it's kind of nuts you know in terms
of this this whole thing going but what
it also shows here and really what he
what he basically tells us is that the
amount of energy and the amount of focus
necessary to be able to handle this much
power while it's within the abilities of
future Thanos to contain these abilities
it's a whole other thing to understand
how to use them effectively and so what
this means is that future Thanos is
still figuring out what it is that he
can do he hasn't fully been able to
channel the totality of the one above
all's power now this is important
because what it means is that it
presents this idea that maybe even the
one above all was limited by its own
imagination and that if Thanos can
essentially Break Free of those
limitations then his power would
transcend the previous one above all's
power the reality of this is that what
future Thanos is doing is hunting around
for Eros it's the thing that's
dominating his mind and the reason why
is because Eros will in some form or
fashion find a way to basically defeat
future Thanos right like Eros could find
a way to defeat his brother it's
possibly only a matter of time before
Thanos loses this power of the one above
all so again it's super cool it's a guy
with the power of God who hasn't quite
figured out how to use it all yet and so
from there you basically pick up with
hero she's like okay one he asks Isaac
the sentient computer right before it's
destroyed by Future Thanos if you can
figure out a way to calculate when the
universe is going to end and they're
able to you know he's able to basically
draw you know kind of create an
algorithm you know in the blink of an
eye like super Advanced you know other
worldly computers do and then
essentially calculate when the universe
is going to end and when Eros and pip
Patrol are teleported there it's just a
giant empty canvas and then future
Thanos simply says let there be an end
in essence Thanos destroys himself the
idea behind this and this is what's
really important here the idea behind
this is that Thanos you know with with
these limitations that were created by
the one above all the indication is that
Thanos is still Bound by those and so
what this really seems to point at is
that the future version of Thanos his
goal after having basically defeated
Eros ensuring that nobody can be in his
way is to basically wipe out everything
in existence and then recreate it as
himself being the one above all he's
wiping the board clean and starting over
again it removes any of the limitations
that were created by the previous one
above all and Thanos is free to recreate
all the Multiverse and the Omniverse as
he sees fit and that's what's so wild
here is because what we do from there is
where Eros and pip Patrol are
essentially dispelled from that future
and sent back to the modern day what it
does you know because of the fact that
they cannot die right so like they're
just kicked back to the modern day what
it does is it picks up with Kane the
Conqueror and Adam Warlock having a
discussion with each other and Kane the
Conqueror not really wanting to
essentially admits that one you know the
kind of feel that he's on right now with
Thanos attaining the power of the one
above all with the actions of Adam
Warlock things like that these are Way
Beyond what Kang is normally used to and
the reality is he's basically being
reduced to a guy who can just help Adam
Warlock out as best he can despite all
the intelligence and all the time
traveling abilities of King he's way out
of his element here more so than that
Adam Warlock throws in this idea and
really kind of gives us some this
amazing notion that future Thanos
operating with all this power again who
has not figured out how to use it and in
the time that he could be taking to
figure out how to use it instead he's
taking that time to focus on finding
Eros this makes him vulnerable this is
basically just a really really really
powerful Thanos and that's why we don't
really have an instance where it's like
well why did you just go back to the
very beginnings of time and stop Eros
from being born if Thanos went back in
time and killed Eros at Birth then
perhaps future Thanos never exists it is
really kind of bound by the rules of
time right the rules of time travel time
manipulation different things like that
and so what we end up doing is picking
up with Adam Warlock right Adam Warlock
basically trying to find a particular
access point within the cosmos basically
an access point that will allow him to
answer the psyche of of future Thanos
right because he's undetectable or at
least it seemed to be that way and then
like entering the future psyche of
Thanos and then in turn you know just
kind of getting a better understanding
of what's going on now the reason why
Adam Warlock is able to do this is not
because he's undetectable that's my
mistake he is right the reason why Adam
Warlock can do this is is because Adam
Warlock is part and partial to Thanos
and so Thanos won't really feel it is
like an ant biting him or anything like
that he'll just kind of see it as the
normal comings and goings of the
Multiverse and how things function and
so on and so forth and because his
attention is off of Adam Warlock Because
he believes that Adam Warlock is now a
negated Factor right he's not in
anything to really worry about instead
with him focusing on Eros it leaves Adam
Warlock open to invade the psyche of
Thanos because he's just not paying
attention but before Adam Warlock can do
that he suddenly met by the arrival of
an unexpected character okay so we are
picking back up again with the infinity
ending and we're actually we're ending
the infinity ending I thought about
titling that Infinity ending ending it
seemed kind of weird but in the last
video we basically left off with the
idea that Adam Warlock was essentially
met out of nowhere by a person that I
kind of left you guys on a cliffhanger
on and the reality is it's not actually
a person but a group of people it's
pretty much all the versions of Adam
Warlock from the past and the funny
thing about this is this goes all the
way back to him right the guy who's not
wearing anything but underwear that's
how Adam Warlock first appeared when he
was in Marvel Comics and this just
different iterations of his character as
time has gone on and the funny thing
about this is that Adam Warlock has
historically been a guy where his
understanding of of the the cosmos and
the Multiverse has kind of been really
Beyond most other people even the cosmic
entities themselves right it's the
reason why Thanos wanted him to become
the New Living Tribunal when we were
reading one of the older Infinity
stories but when you when you get into
this what you end up having is this
scenario where these versions of Adam
really kind of Say No like
self-preservation is more important than
the universe and there's a couple of
reasons why they're coming from this
perspective the first is because they're
sentient beings right it's just the
nature of us as people we care about
ourselves more than we care about other
things right it's just the way that we
are and so what we also have here is the
notion that Adam Warlock can never truly
die and so no matter no matter what
happens in this universe where it ends
or where it returns Adam Warlock will
essentially always end up returning and
his other cells sort of recognize this
right but the idea of Adam Warlock and
this really kind of seems to be an
ideology for his character that's
changed over the years but the ideology
of Adam Adam warlock at this point in
time is saving the universe is the most
important thing and in reality it's not
as though they're killing off the entire
universe of people it's quite the
opposite defeat one guy in order to save
all of creation right is classic
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and so
it's a cool perception here it's a cool
notion here because Adam Warlock has
been without his soul gem for quite some
time now the reality is Adam Warlock
doesn't really need the soul gem I mean
it kind of helps to bolster his power a
bit but he never really needed it I mean
he's exceedingly powerful even without
the gym but what he ends up doing with
these various Guys these various
versions of himself is basically
snatching the soul gem off of one of
their heads and then essentially
overpowering all the others now we don't
really know exactly what happens to them
but regardless of the situation the
result is that Adam Warlock ends up
coming out on top and so following this
he basically dives through a portal and
into the consciousness of Thanos now
this is not the first time this has
happened they've been inside each
other's minds before in the subconscious
mind of Adam Warlock it's all about
death and rebirth right people riding an
elevator all the way up to the top of
this Cliff more or less falling off
dying and then getting back up and doing
it all over again the cycle of death and
rebirth constantly taking place with
Thanos it was just nihilism reign
supreme right just just death and
destruction and so Adam kind of dives
into the mind of the one above all
Thanos that we're talking about now and
the funny thing about this is that each
one of these places that he sees is now
an entire universe unto itself Adam
Warlock is hopping from one Universe to
the next within the mind of one above
all Thanos but that's more or less
what's going on here one of the first
memories he sees or one of the first
things he sees is Thanos as a little kid
who basically breaks a lamp now the
funny thing about this is we can look at
this a couple different ways right we
can look at this story as being out of
continuity or we can look at the story
being in continuity and the reason why
is because suicon's currently there for
those of you guys who read the rise and
fall of Thanos I think it was I think it
was Ed rubaker or Jason Aaron one of
those two who wrote it uh we basically
got The Life and Times of Thanos right
all the events that led to him in
encountering mistress death for the very
first time and then going forward and
becoming the villain that we that we all
know and love in the early days sweet
song and when I say early days I mean
like almost immediately after giving
birth but srisan tried to kill Thanos
because she saw him was about Omen and
had a vision that his actions would lead
to the downfall and the destructions of
everybody on Titan which it did and so
she tried to take him out and ultimately
she was thrown in a mental institution
and so if this story is in continuity at
the time that Thanos is this age suisan
should be in a mental institution but
she's not she's there so that kind of
leads us to believe that either it was
Jim Sterling kind of trying to correct
things and saying no no no this is how
it should be or it's not in continuity
but the other funny thing that kind of
comes out of this is Eros and pip the
troll now remember these are two guys
and while they're not necessarily
bungling buffoons they certainly don't
have any real kind of concrete plan
right their plan here to try to stop
future Thanos from acquiring all this
insane power capturing his modern day
self and then going on to become the one
above all their whole attempt to
basically stop that is to convince
Thanos that he's a good guy that he's
cool you know and that like Eros loves
him and that's basically it right like
words don't win conflicts more or less
and so because of that we end up kind of
jumping through these different moments
and thanos's life and you kind of have
Thanos when he's relatively Young when
he's you know kind of going through that
that age of of bodies changing in
puberty and he's kind of put on a few
pounds you know and drinking a soda it
looks like and Eros tries to convince
Thanos like he's a cool guy you know the
Thanos is great that Eros loves him and
it is really EOS like trying to convince
Thanos of this right the next time they
appear is when Thanos is feeding some
bullies to some monsters in a cave
because the bullies needed to understand
their place in the bigger picture
following that like it's Thanos
basically launching an attack and
destroying the entire planet uh planet
of Titan all these different things that
are going on with Thanos committing
these acts and as this is going on we
have two versions of Thanos here that's
one thing to keep in mind we've got
essentially what amounts to present-day
Thanos or the easiest way to think about
it and then we've got future Thanos and
if you guys recall in the last video we
talked about this right future Thanos
was the one that was trying to attain
the power to become the one above all
present-day Thanos is the one who is
being used in order to follow in those
footsteps and assure that that path was
actually followed and one present-day
Thanos went through all those steps then
he was absorbed by Future Thanos to
ensure that nothing would ever go wrong
and that's why you see this version of
Thanos as sort of hovering in a tank
this is present day Thanos being held
prisoner by his future self and so Eros
and them basically arriving to what's
actually thanos's first appearance in
Marvel Comics when he fought Iron Man in
terms of his uh chronological
appearances we have them showing up in
instances like during the events of
Infinity Gauntlet these really cool
little moments here and there and it's
one of these things where present-day
Thanos kind of says okay like I can
reach out basically psychically and I
can communicate with them right I can
talk to them through my past self
basically and that's what you see
playing out here right like Eros and his
guys will show up to a particular point
in time and then Thanos will talk to
them and as they basically kind of run
over their plan but they only get brief
moments right they only get these really
really small moments and the reason why
this is kind of being held off the
reason why these moments are only ever
so short is because present-day Thanos
realizes that if they stop and they talk
for too long it'll create abnormalities
in the time stream that his future
version will become aware of and then
start tracing them down and ultimately
realizing what it is that Eros and pit
Patrol are trying to do and at the end
of the day again it doesn't really
matter they're not actually doing
anything uh but it is kind of a cool
little effort right it is a cool attempt
one of the other funny things to come
matter this is that because of all these
paradoxes and all these shifts that Eros
and hip Patrol are making they end up
showing up at a future point in time and
we have the cosmic entities but they're
different this right here actually
doesn't really make any sense and the
reason why is if you understand the
nature of cosmic entities they exist in
two forms right they exist in their true
form which is an abstract form it has no
true physical form right they're just an
ideology if you had like the desire to
go get something to eat it would be like
if that desire to eat could get up and
walk around right that thought that
concept could get up and move that's
what a cosmic entity is now when Cosmic
entities appear in a physical form they
go to the dimension of manifestations
and they basically receive a form from
anthropomorpho and then they show up in
the main Marvel Universe in a physical
form but it's just one of these these
these small little things right so you
know it's a it's a cool little moment
it's a little a little wonky and a
little crazy but again that's kind of
what we're dealing with here are sort of
these escapades of jumping back and
forth through time and so when Eros is
talking to present-day Thanos when they
say like like I guess we can work
together and Eros is very much unsure
about this because it's trust testing a
guy who's well known for betrayal Thanos
is kind of like at the end of the day
our goals are basically Mutual here at
the end of the day like we're trying to
achieve the same goal I'm currently
trapped in the essence more or less of
My Future Self come there rescue me and
then like we'll save the day and the
cool thing about that is that when that
happens when Eros shows up it's not
really hero saving Thanos instead Eros
is seemingly kind of whisked away Eros
just sort of says like this isn't right
this isn't how it's supposed to be and
he just ends up taking off Adam Warlock
peeps his head in to see what Eros is
doing while he's on his journey and then
basically you know once once that
happens Adam Warlock kind of Pops back
in or at least sort of disappears for a
second when future Thanos shows up and
the reason why this matters is because
future Thanos as we know was looking for
Eros not to kill him or to capture him
but because with Eros existing outside
of life and death then it was basically
impossible for one above all Thanos to
track him down now again this is Jim
Sterling shifting things around this is
Jim Sterling changing things under
normal circumstances and everything up
to this point it's not how the one above
all worked everything that is is the one
above all the face that you see when it
speaks to things is no different than
eternity popping up and then like
talking to somebody but it's just the
entirety of the Omniverse and all things
coalescing in the form of a face that
can have a conversation with you with
that being the case anything even if
it's outside the realm of life and death
is still part of the one above all if it
exists if it talks if it's if it's
anything that can be drawn or written it
exists as part of the one above all so
again Jim Sterling is kind of Shifting
things up and saying that's not
necessarily the case here right like you
know anything that exists outside of
life and death meaning it can't truly
die it's outside the one above all's
purview because it's considered an
anomaly right which is kind of crazy to
sort of limit the power of the one above
all and a lot of you guys are making
comments about that you were saying like
well I guess now he's just the one above
most here's what it is and you're not
wrong right you're not entirely wrong
the one above pretty much most things
unless the plot calls for him to not be
above things like that's basically what
it is you know and so it's it's kind of
wild here but with Eros having popped up
and basically shown up in the essence of
future Thanos to rescue present-day
Thanos by default he made himself part
of future Thanos therefore everything is
now complete right future Thanos has
attained this goal of tracking down Eros
and basically making Eros a part of
himself even if it was only because Eros
just sort of walked into it right so
it's essentially Thanos was trying to
get euros into a house and Eros just
sort of wandered in there on his own
that's really kind of what this is right
now when future Thanos basically leaves
Adam Warlock then pops up and that's
when present-day Thanos is like you have
to free me from this prison where the
the response of Adam Warlock is no I'm
not going to do that you have to trust
me here you need to stay here this is
all part of my plan now Thanos initially
sort of questions it and isn't really
sure but the reality is that Adam
Warlock is kind of a master planner it's
one of these things where when Adam
Warlock comes up with a plan it's not
really to be questioned the issue with
this is we're talking about Uncharted
Territory it's one thing to create a
plan just have Thanos lose The Infinity
Gauntlet because he gets carried away
with himself and because warlock
understands thanos's subconscious mind
and how he thinks it's another to form a
plan against a seemingly Nai omnipotent
being that cannot truly be destroyed by
anybody here or really anything in
existence right so you know like I have
a plan to defeat a being that cannot be
defeated that's kind of what that what
that sort of comes down to and it's a
little wild there because what Adam
Warlock ends up doing is basically
watching all of this go down right the
idea was okay let's let this play out
and let's see what happens it's a
dangerous Gambit because this could fail
in in the most spectacular sense but
future Thanos ends up doing what he
intended to do he ends up wiping away
all of reality now we didn't know what
the motivation was before but we
currently do now and the idea is that
future Thanos looks around and it's
almost kind of agreeable in terms of
what it is that he's doing and why he's
doing it right at the end of the day he
kind of makes this argument between
utilitarianism and deontological ethics
the intentions versus actions let's say
for example that like you see a homeless
man and you give that homeless man five
bucks right your idea is to just give
that guy five bucks to help him along
his way but what if in reality by giving
him that five dollars all you've done is
make him a target for somebody else
because he didn't earn that five dollars
he doesn't know how to keep it and
because he didn't know how to keep it
either he's swindled by somebody who
dupes him out of it or he's not
physically capable of holding it on his
own somebody beats him up and then takes
it would he have died had you not given
him that five dollars that's the the
philosophical quandary that we're
talking about here and depending on what
philosophical Viewpoint you come from
whether you're at fault or not begins to
shift if we say the only thing that
matters is intention right that's the
only thing that really matters here is
intention then at the end of the day
it's like then your intention was to
make that guy's life better and that's
where your responsibility stops right
that's where it ends as far as you're
concerned you did what you thought was a
good thing done right we're we're
finished there from there then it starts
going into things like okay if all that
matters is action then you gave that guy
five dollars but then you also cost him
his life and so is your act more well
you know that's the kind of issue that
you run into here and so it's one of
these things where Thanos really kind of
looks at it and says the only thing that
really matters in this universe matters
in this world is actions right what
people's intentions are don't matter
what matters are deeds and that
everything is just a giant contest right
even the cosmic entities seek to be
Supreme Over the other in some form or
fashion despite the fact that they're
designed to be immutable despite the
fact that they're designed to be these
forces that represent idea is and they
don't really seek to better one another
at the end of the day there's still a
kind of contest there and so thanos's
responses then we'll recreate things
loyalty was conceived to deceive people
trust is a fantasy for fools and is
basically played upon by Scoundrels who
look to exploit the universe as it
exists now is one of naivety it's people
who believe they can change the universe
and so on by just doing good things or
believing good things but at the end of
the day like it's a screwed up and
terrible place this seems to be like the
core perspective of Thanos and so with
that being the case he says okay then
let's recreate everything and so with
that going down you know with that
happening the way that it does you know
he basically goes to essentially
recreate all of existence and it offers
this momentary Gambit right when you
have Adam Warlock who's essentially
outside the existing Multiverse watching
it all go down right once he Retreats
outside of Thanos and kind of goes back
to this outside the Multiverse kind of
space then in turn like once future
Thanos wipes everything out of existence
and then seems to recreate everything we
kind of get this brief moment where
present-day Thanos basically says okay
now's the chance to actually do
something I get this brief moment to
basically take this action and then
basically Adam Warlock just kind of
wakes up in the void without any real
indication of where he is or where he's
at he's just kind of out in this total
Oblivion of absolute nothingness and the
indication is that he's totally outside
of all recreated existence the Omniverse
as it exists he's way out there to give
you perspective this is more or less
just stories that have not been told yet
and so with him being out there out in
the void out in the nothingness there's
no stars no planets no nothing just
infinite Blackness but he ends up
getting this kind of Lifeline that comes
through a sort of portal where he's
basically yanked forward by Kane the
Conqueror and that was the idea was to
to really have Kang basically grab Eros
and pip Patrol to ensure they stayed
alive Adam Warlock didn't quite know
what would happen to him but the more
important thing was to ensure that
everything was safe and the plan
basically went as he expected that in
this moment of vulnerability in this
moment where future Thanos had basically
dispersed his energy or attempted to
disperse his energy present-day Thanos
basically sees that power for himself
that after seizing all that power of the
one above all from his future
counterpart because of the fact that
present-day Thanos never really agreed
with his future camera part his future
version ceased to exist just by virtue
of destroying his Essence more or less
and then present-day Thanos used the
power of the one above all to reset
everything back to normal and this is
where the story totally falls short and
the reason why is because we don't see
any of that happen it's all explained to
Adam Warlock by Kane the Conqueror who
watched it all go down right so Adam
Warlock wasn't even really a part of it
he wasn't a part of seeing everything
recreated and all that kind of stuff
some will probably say well we didn't
need to see that others will say
something something Jim Starlin higher
plane of reasoning who knows but
whatever the case is it's basically one
of these things where like we missed out
on what could have been a really really
cool appearance of a story or some
Exposition and some explanation there in
terms of like why Thanos did what he did
in terms of like from his perspective
because we know why he did what he did
and we get the exposition it's just from
some time traveling guy that makes
stories overly complicated and so it's
like okay that's kind of weird and so
they kind of make a final stop in Adam
Warlock of course again still in
possession of the Soul Stone presents
the the reality Stone to Thanos and the
truth and this is kind of the important
thing here the truth is that it's
entirely possible that his future self
could get carried away with power again
and the entire process could repeat
itself but it's one of these things
where Adam Warlock trusts Thanos right
he trusts the character of Thanos to do
what needs to be done not only that it
basically we kind of have this this sort
of assumption that we have to make that
if present-day Thanos did take the power
of the one above all from his future
counterpart and then set everything back
that he may have just kind of walked the
time stream to find out exactly what
went wrong or where he kind of lived
through the time stream so he knows the
mistakes that he made and we kind of
have to assume that like if he did set
everything back he's aware of of himself
like he's aware of like what he would
what he would become or something like
that it's not clearly explained it's not
clearly defined and I think that's kind
of one of the issues here it sort of
leaves things pretty ambiguous right and
it really feels like the ending in the
story was wrapped up super fast right it
was just wrapped up very very quickly
and it sort of left a bit to be desired
but at the end of the day things just
kind of go back to the way they were
before right everything just sort of
goes back to normal and then you kind of
have Adam Warlock who's just sort of
sitting there in a bar you know out in
or really in Stalin's bars what they
call a gym someone named a bar after
himself but he just kind of sitting in a
bar and just sort of chilling there and
people kind of have this concern that
things are not necessarily going back
for the better but at the end of the day
we won't truly know as far as I'm aware
this is the last of the infinity stories
that Jim starlin's right of course I
think Infinity finale was also supposed
to be the last one and it wasn't but at
the end of the day this is really a word
just kind of wraps up so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob Corp if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
peace